[Music]
evolution the natural process that
shaped all life and can lead from this
to this it's driven by random genetic
mutation and natural selection random
mutations create variation sometimes a
change gives an advantage like cells
that can detect light to help seek out
safer environments survivors pass along
the changes to future generations
further changes can occur over many
generations and sometimes hundreds of
millions of years fast forward to today
now we have molecular tools that can
allow us to alter the direction that
life takes including our own the most
accurate and effective tool yet for gene
editing is called CRISPR we can use it
to essentially rewrite any gene however
we choose potentially fixing mutations
that cause disease the most common
analogy for how CRISPR works is the find
and replace function of a word processor
and with CRISPR what used to take nature
millions of years can now be done in a
lab in just days
it is a groundbreaking tool with
unprecedented power it shows promise for
curing cancers ALS and many other
diseases
we've already engineered malaria proof
mosquitoes and may create mice immune to
Lyme disease
but possessing the power to forever
alter the future of life raises
difficult questions
what could justify genetically modifying
the ecology around us should we move
beyond curing diseases to making other
genetic enhancements are there any lies
we shouldn't cross how can we avoid the
misuse of this powerful technology and
can humanity even agree on the future of
a very own genetic destiny we're gonna
hear from a range of experts working on
different aspects of CRISPR which stands
for cultured regularly interspaced short
palindromic repeats Wow but we are not
going to let that scare us are we no so
allow me to introduce our distinguished
panel
Josephine Johnston is a bioethicist
and lawyer at the Hastings Center she
works on the ethics of emerging bio
technologies with a focus on their use
in reproduction psychiatry genetics and
neuroscience
so please welcome Josephine Johnston is
a member of the US National Academy of
Sciences and has served on several
national research committees studying
the environmental and health effects of
the commercialization of genetically
engineered crops please say hello to
Fred Gould
Samuel Sternberg is an assistant
professor in the Department of
Biochemistry and molecular biophysics at
Columbia University he is the co-author
with Jennifer Doudna of a crack in
creation the unthinkable power to
control evolution Sam Sternberg Neville
sanjana
is on the faculty of the New York genome
Center an assistant professor in the
department's of biology and neuroscience
and physiology at New York University
Neville sanjeok so first we're going to
start with an overview of the great
potential of this technology CRISPR in
terms of human diseases research is
underway on a number of conditions and
I'm just gonna throw it first off to
Neville right away don't be surprised
what the range of diseases is that
CRISPR has the potential to cure yes I
think in the last few years it's had
just a huge impact across biomedical
science and some of the diseases are
very common diseases what a lot of us
know folks who have cancer
cancers like skin cancer or lung cancer
blood cancers there's also a lot of non
cancer applications I think with CRISPR
- blood diseases like sickle cell anemia
or beta thalassemia and other diseases
that are being worked on right now with
CRISPR or some eye diseases some
diseases of the retina that result in
blindness so I know that there's been a
lot of research on mice and monkeys but
none of this has applied to humans yet
has it there there are clinical trials
either underway depending on in some
countries already underway and
definitely in advanced planning stages
in US and Europe and China
I heard that China actually did use
CRISPR for an eye disease right on one
person do we know what the outcome was I
don't think that's been published yet
but there's actually a number of
clinical trials for cancer that have
started in China
where you use CRISPR to edit immune
cells that actually get delivered back
into patients to hunt down cancerous
cells of the body so I don't think it's
too early to say how effective these
treatments are going to be but there's a
lot of hope I think across the
scientific community that there's kind
of this new age of precision medicine
using gene editing to treat some of
these more common genetic diseases or
cancers in a fundamentally new way so
Fred just as an overview just to start
the whole discussion tell us about
crispers potential in plants and animals
yeah well especially in plants there's
the possibility of using CRISPR to
change the genetic composition of some
of our crop plants to make them more
resistant to plant diseases and that
could decrease the use of insecticides
or herbicides and also of fungicides and
so on so that's been a very important
contribution and with animals the corn
--less cow was recently produced you
know the idea yeah so well Bulls will
have horns and typically you have to do
sort of a surgical operation to point so
the idea that you could engineer these
cattle not to have horns is something
that has been done by regular breeding
but could also be done using those
things but a lot of these things are
just starting to be considered and are
not actually on the market yet you know
I did a story on 60 minutes about 10
years ago on a program to bring back
extinct animals and I've read that
CRISPR may be used in that kind of an
effort Sam I think is a book that's
coming out or has come out using CRISPR
to resurrect woolly mammoths now we had
a discussion earlier I like how
realistic is that actually I would still
put it personally in the box of science
fiction but that the point is we
actually you know scientists have
decoded the entire genetic sequence of
the woolly mammoth from fossil samples
from preserved specimens and you can
compare the Asian elephant you know
and the woolly mammoth genome pinpoint
all the precise DNA changes between the
two and now use this powerful gene
editing technology to actually go into
Asian elephant cells and start changing
individual genes one at a time from the
version that modern-day elephants have
to the version that we mammoths once had
well that's the part that I think no
one's working out IVF and an elephant
and I you know the gestation time of
elephants is like two years and you know
that's the big the big question could
you ever actually give birth to
something that even resembled a woolly
mammoth I'd say not in my lifetime I
would guess but if you read the new
stories about it people say five ten
years Josefin just as an overview what
are some of the negative aspects of this
as a bio ethicist well the first thing I
would say is I think because it's a
platform technology with so many
different uses it's not sort of just a
good or a bad technology or and the
users really vary but people who are
speaking about some of the concerns they
might have across these different
potential uses are you know concerned
about a real range of things from safety
type questions about like how would we
know could people create sort of weapons
out of using these technologies that's
one sort of really sort of very clearly
dangerous and potentially frightening
scenarios and that people are looking at
all the way across the questions around
how appropriate it is for humans to have
such a lot of control over the genes of
our selves our children or animals and
so what ends like what are we pursuing
what's the purpose of it so there are a
lot of questions raised right across
those different uses and as we move
forward we'll be discussing the pros and
cons so we set the stage but let's go
back in history a little bit and talk
about all the different ways that we
were manipulating an evolution and our
genes before CRISPR and for good or bad
so Fred start out with us on the plants
and the manipulation of
planet genetics right so I think that
many of you probably do know that your
plants didn't just arise from nowhere
they were almost all bred by farmers and
by technicians over thousands of years
and so we often use the example of
teosinte which is a sort of a weed that
grows in Mexico with a very small seed
pot and that has been over time changed
by farmers who have just selected the
best plants that had the most nutrition
over time to bigger and bigger corn and
today we have modern corn as a result of
that so we also have the same thing with
our animals both in terms of farm
animals but also think about your dogs
and cats think about the odd goldfish
you can buy in a store we've manipulated
animals and plants for a long period of
time and what about food who wants to
tackle food sure sure genetically
modified today you know so I think it's
a very so that's genetically modified ok
so I just told you about teosinte being
bred to become the modern-day corn plant
that is genetically modified from
teosinte but when people talk typically
about genetically modified or GMOs
you're talking about something that has
been engineered and we have to talk
about the difference between that right
so and I think a lot of it goes back to
a cultural thing about what is natural
and what is not natural and it's natural
to just save seeds that are better and
better and move ahead it's most people
will say that is natural but they
wouldn't say that it's natural to take
cells out of a plant and insert DNA in
them to make them different and so we
have about 80 to 90% of our corn soybean
and cotton in the United States has been
developed that way genetically
genetically engineered and I like to use
the term genetically
because it's engineering right in the
sense that it's actually thinking about
an architectural plan of a plant and
changing it as opposed to something that
you just do tinkering with it as some
people would say so that's a big change
in terms of how people relate to
something that's been developed those
different ways and to go back and say
that what's the difference between a
plant that has the same characteristics
let's say you change a corn plant from
being yellow to being blue based on
conventional breeding like the folks in
Mexico have done but then you do the
same thing using genetic engineering is
that different would you accept it more
if it was done one way
I think people respond very strongly
because of cultural values and actually
there was a map of you know where these
engineered crops are grown and in the
United States we grow about 10 or more
different genetically engineered crops
in Mexico they grow genetically
engineered soy beans and genetically
engineered cotton but they don't allow
genetically engineered maize or corn
because that's sacred to them you know
if you look at Diego Rivera's paintings
corn is a main sacred object so under
those kind of conditions there's a
cultural thing against having something
that's been built artificially that's a
map yeah it's telling us where GMOs are
genetically engineered yeah crops right
are what accept it where they where
they're grown commercially within the
legal framework of regulation and China
is a very good example where they have
almost a hundred percent genetically
engineered cotton but in terms of
legally grown rice there is zero percent
genetically engineered rice and it
sometimes surprises people in a top-down
supposed Society the government would
like to have genetic engine but they
have a very big Greenpeace movement in
China surprises Americans and that they
don't trust that their rice would be
safe if it was genetically engineered
Josephine do you think this tampering
tinkering modifying
nature is part of human nature
have we been always doing it as long as
there's been a recording of what we've
done so there yeah probably
and they doesn't really tell us if it's
good or bad right there are lots of
things we have been doing for centuries
if not millennia that I you know how
good and some of them are also not good
wars Wow so there are a lot of things
that are we know naturally and they may
or may not be good good or bad may
depend on your culture okay yeah I could
also depend I mean there are a lot of
some of the interesting differences I
guess between those two different ways
of getting blue corn are also to do with
the time frame right the speed the
ability to look at something developing
in in concert with its surroundings that
you just when you speed something up you
you may or may not also miss certain
aspects of it so I there are many things
I think that people are objecting to
when they raise concerns about
genetically modified foods and safety is
maybe one of them but there are also
issues around who controls the food
supply having a limited diversity of
crops ultimately whether or not there
are certain companies who then have a
lot of power over things that farmers
have actually been doing for centuries
their own way so there are a lot of
other issues in there I think also
around trust that are not just
represented by concerns about safety
yeah Sam jump up to the 70s and 80s and
to the modern era of genetic technology
and what were the tools that we used
after we understood more about the
genome before CRISPR you see before
CRISPR so Fred just brought up you know
GMO or genetically engineered foods and
the kinds of crops we have like you know
corn rice these other ones those were
using recombinant DNA so you know in the
70s there was this revolution where
researchers developed a set of tools
that they could use to piece together
bits of DNA in test tubes so the first
time that you could really isolate
specific genes you could package them in
different ways and you could actually
introduce that genetic material into eco
life or design or bacterial strains into
plants into animals you could make
genetically engineered mice because of
this ability to manipulate DNA inside of
the laboratory now it's not the same
precision for making changes that we
might have today but Nevel I think you
were going to talk about this picture
that these are some some mice that you
developed yourself huh
this is a CRISPR this is not my site
develop myself but these these are mice
that have a protein from jellyfish so
jellyfish many species of jellyfish have
this naturally produced this green
fluorescent protein and so these mice
were developed to be able to visualize
different cells so we were using them to
actually look to see how the axons of
neurons grows during my PhD work and
find their neighbors and connect up in
the brain and so it's very nice to be
able to visualize these with this green
fluorescent protein and so this is a so
they glowed in the dark
they can glow in blacklight exactly so
they're their party mice but they're
very useful for science so this was done
by a Japanese group that introduced not
in the CRISPR era but randomly
introduced this trans gene this we
called a trans gene because it comes
originally from a different species from
the jellyfish randomly into into the
mouse genome it sounds doesn't sound
I've read that even with CRISPR but
we're going to stay away from that even
with CRISPR that all the discoveries
have been have come because you've
studied nature and you've looked at what
nature had done and then you build on
that so the basis of both what you're
talking about and CRISPR comes from
observing the way nature would move
forward exactly so that that's why being
a bioengineering I mean Sam can talk
just about why being a bioengineer I
think is so exciting yeah I mean it's a
bit self justifying my career choice but
it's fun because there's so much in
I think in nature and so many useful
tools have been created over a millennia
of evolution on this planet and I think
the tool that we're talking about today
CRISPR and and other tools are you know
it's it's an exciting thing to do to be
able to see these working in one context
in nature and then try and use them
perhaps translationally for medicine or
for plants so as as we come up to today
with all the fears that people have
about GMOs and the kind of crossbreeding
Xand the things you're talking about
have any of the fears been realized why
are why is the public so against GMOs I
think they're probably people have
different reasons that they're concerned
I do think that the safety of them just
to eat hasn't been explored or explained
adequately so it's been around for a
long time well well I would say so we
have been eating genetically engineered
corn in the United States since 1996 so
we've had quite a few years of eating
that genetically engineered corn but the
question is how would you know if it was
doing something and I would just say you
know I spent quite a while chairing a
committee with the National Academies
looking at the safety and looking at the
testing that was done as many of you
have probably seen newspapers or on the
internet of these rats with big tumors
and things but you know looking through
those you know from GMOs I mean it's
it's something that cruises around the
internet all the time
but when you look at it carefully not
all the tests have been done have been
appropriate or powerful enough to say if
there's a small difference but if you
take all the testing that's been done
over this long period of time there's no
evidence at all that has emerged either
from the actual animal testing or even
we did a comparison of people who live
in the US and Canada where GMOs are
prevalent to people who live in the UK
or the EU where they haven't been him to
ask these questions about whether
chronic diseases have increased faster
in the US and Canada than what you see
in the EU and the UK and when you look
at it numbers of things everywhere from
diabetes to cancer different kinds of
cancer piece you don't see any change
different in the US and Canada compared
to the EU in the UK now somebody could
say well that hasn't been a long enough
period of time but you know science is
always that way I think probably many of
you know that if you live long enough
you find out that eggs are good or bad
or salt you should have this much or
that much you know science changes but I
think that no really strong acute
changes have occurred based on people
you know company countries where they
eat GMOs how CRISPR came to be the
creation story is an amazing one made
possible by the work of many labs all
around the world so my first question at
this stage is how does it work
and we're gonna watch a short primer
that was produced by one of the CRISPR
pioneers Jennifer Doudna is going to
teach us how it works
[Music]
CRISPR is a technology for changing the
sequence of DNA in cells in a precise
fashion to correct mutations that might
otherwise cause disease so scientists
can actually change an individual base
pair in the in the more than 3 billion
base pairs in a human cell
the fun thing about the CRISPR
technology for me is that this is a
project that started off as a basic
science curiosity driven project it was
a collaboration between my lab and the
lab of Immanuel Sharpe on ta we teamed
up to discover the function of the
protein cast line and how it acts to
disrupt viral DNA in bacteria that have
a viral infection we came to understand
the way that cast line is programmed by
RNA molecules in bacteria to recognize
specific DNA sequences and then make a
break in the DNA we figured out that we
could actually program cast line to cut
any DNA sequence by redesigning the way
the guide RNA and the protein is being
used in cells that understanding led to
really the aha moment realizing that
this could be actually a very powerful
technology in animal and plant cells
it's very exciting because it's going to
enable a lot of science to be done that
was impossible to do in the past so Sam
you worked with Jennifer Doudna Dowd now
am I saying it right in her lab so tell
us your role but also help explain I I
was confused cast nine is is it a
bacteria I always like to stress that
there's CRISPR technology which is what
we think of when we talk about gene
editing making these genetic changes in
human cells and plants animals but what
got us all interested in CRISPR in the
first place was this fundamental
question she just talked about which has
nothing to do with higher organisms but
just bacteria and thinking about how
bacteria can stay healthy when they're
growing in the soil and the human gut
every place that bacteria reside they're
actually being constantly bombarded by
viruses and these bacterial viruses are
the most prevalent form of life on Earth
actually they outnumber even the grains
of sand on the planet there
more viral particles that infect
bacteria and so there's this big
question how do bacteria protect
themselves and it's been known since the
middle of the 20th century that they
have innate immune system as much like
humans do but what what a number of
different research groups discovered in
the mid-2000s is that they have this
other form of immunity called CRISPR
which uses a pair of molecular scissors
so this kind of oversimplified schematic
on the slide where they actually
recognize DNA from a virus during an
infection and they slice it in half and
that leads to the viral genome or the
viral genetic code being destroyed and
the bacteria can survive the infection
CRISPR is that also called CRISPR yeah
CRISPR has kind of become this umbrella
term to it really what it refers to is
the overall immune system but the star
player that's now trans transformed gene
editing technology is a particular
enzyme called caste 9 and the caste is
actually an acronym that comes from
CRISPR associated so that Sosuke sign is
not a bacteria it's a bacterial enzyme
so a protein molecule one specific
protein that some bacteria produce and
actually the the genesis story was done
in a bacterium called streptococcus
thermophilus you eat it every day you
have a bowl of yogurt so it's the main
workhorse to ferment milk into yogurt
and other dairy products and it was a
company that was trying to make these
bacterial fermentation cultures more
virus resistant that led to the
discovery of CRISPR actually so every
time you eat yogurt you're eating CRISPR
actually but it was the discovery that
you can take these specific pieces out
of those bacteria and put them in a
human cell or a plant cell or an animal
cell that led to this revolution in gene
editing to me it's it's really
fascinating I think you mentioned this
but it's worth stressing this that this
is an adaptive immune system in bacteria
bacteria are single tiny single-celled
organisms you know where these whatever
trillions of interact
cells that make us up and we have an
adaptive immune system we know we have
antibodies and we have T cells that
fight off infections but that's because
we have so many cells but it's to me
it's just mind-blowing still that a
single cell a tiny one-celled organism
has an adaptive immune system meaning
that word adaptive means it can have a
memory of previous invaders previous
viruses that it's encountered which it
keeps in this in this crisper area of
its genome and then can when it sees
something that matches that memory as
Sam said it's a molecular scissors it
can cut it and get rid of it before it
harms and sickens the bacteria it's a
very cool let's do a round will start
with Nevele come all the way around tell
us in your own and from your own
perspective in your own words what you
think is so revolutionary about CRISPR
oh okay that's that's a good question
with so revolutionary about CRISPR
yeah I mean it's it's kind of hard I
think to overstate that what what it's
enabled us to do so basically one thing
that we as biologist and geneticist have
been limited in some ways is we have
this concept in biology of a genetic
model organism so you might hear a lot
of studies that involve either bacteria
or fruit flies or mice and you might
wonder well why do scientists just love
these couple organisms that I keep
hearing about why do I care so much
about mice but not about rats is it just
a mice or cuter and scientists like
using cute animals
there's a reason actually that that
they've kind of fixated on a few
different organisms and that's because
those are genetic model organisms
meaning their genomes have been easier
to manipulate so we can understand what
changes in their DNA in their in their
genetic code what they what they do to
those animals we can understand the
connection between the DNA the genotype
and the phenotype how it looks to us how
the animal behaves and that's been the
case up until very very recently and I
think the one of the real breakthroughs
and the CRISPR era is the idea of the
genetic model organism is is very
different now because everything it can
be a genetic model organism including
what a lot of people consider the most
important or
or model organism which is us we'd like
to study something to understand about
how our genes result in maybe diseases
that that we get and how we can repair
those those defects and so human cells
the DNA was actually quite hard to
manipulate until quite until recently
and really any organism now is a genetic
model organism with crispy I'm supposed
to follow that I guess for me I mean I
love your you're wondering about how
does this work because that's what's
gotten me excited is really the
mechanics of the whole process and I
think what is often unappreciated about
even CRISPR is that it's become a moving
target because there's no one thing that
defines CRISPR because what we've
discovered over the last ten years or so
is that there are all different flavors
of CRISPR where the Cassadine protein
that we've been talking about isn't even
present where different strains or
different groups of bacteria have
evolved different types of enzymes that
might work similarly but do completely
different things or we're not even edit
DNA but edit RNA and one thing that a
lot of researchers are doing that was
harnessing continuing to harness nature
and kind of remain inspired by what
bacteria and other microorganisms have
evolved to be able to do over
evolutionary time and then think about
how can we re-engineered and use it and
more and more creative ways to just
solve problems okay good yeah okay so
there we go so I take this to a higher
level that was pretty high Fred I'm an
entomologist I read an entomology well
we were right so I study insects and
we're concerned specifically about
agricultural and you know insects pests
on crops but also mosquitoes that
transmit diseases and one of the most
talked about is malaria and when we
think about using CRISPR to
decrease to see sometimes we're thinking
about manipulating humans so they won't
get the disease and so on but with
something like malaria that is
transmitted by a mosquito people have
been working for many years with
transgenic mosquitoes where you've
changed the genes to make it so the
mosquito can't transmit malaria it
sounds really good but think about it if
you release a couple of thousand
mosquitoes that you've bred in the lab
they're gonna be millions of other
mosquitoes that do transmit the disease
so what we've been working towards for a
long time is a way to get those genes to
move into the population based on being
inherited more than expectations by
Mendelian inheritance so that it'll push
the gene into the population and people
have worked for a long time on how to do
that and what has happened with this
CRISPR technology that came from the
biomedical researchers was this
recognition that what they're trying to
do is put the gene into an organism and
have it function but that's just a
one-off thing and the idea is that once
you put that gene in you can use
different manipulations so that it
automatically continues to put itself
into new organisms so when you give
birth all of your offspring will have
those genes instead of half of them so
if you think about linking that with a
gene for not transmitting malaria all of
a sudden that mosquito population
becomes a nuisance but not something
that's transmitting malaria so that's
exciting
that's really exciting in my lifetime
this is the first time I have had a you
know I've in my lifetime that we've
actually seemed to have the means not
just to select the genes of future
generations but to actually change them
and so that's monument or prospect it
doesn't anything someone's doing right
now that we know about but it's
certainly like dangling there is a much
more real prospect so decades are people
thinking about being able to do
something like that to actually
potentially being able to do that is
monumental and the other thing that's
come along with that I think was this
really I think brave and really
important move
Jennifer Doudna and other people
involved in the development of
technology made which was immediately
asking for an international conversation
about that potential so that moment of
open science and raising questions about
your own work and acknowledging that you
the scientists are looking for everyone
else to join in the conversation that's
a monumental moment as well I want to
move us though into the whole question
about genetic changes in the human body
and medicine and so let's divide this up
first let's talk about non heritable
diseases and then then we'll talk about
heritable so non heritable diseases some
cancers some blindness what benefits
does CRISPR offer over the earlier
technologies in this whole area of non
heritable Samer nevel either one of you
sure I don't know address the non
heritable part exactly but I think the
key I mean we talked about this earlier
but really the the key property has been
the easy programmability that this is
really getting into the realm of almost
like programming your computer it's
something that we can do in except we do
it in the lab but quite easily and so
it's enabled us to ask questions really
of a different scale so in you know
previous decades you'd often have a
geneticist who spent their entire career
working really just closely focusing on
one gene and really exploring what
happens you know where that gene is
maybe mutated or has other other changes
to it and or what patients with with
with conditions that involved that gene
look like but here with this easy
program ability we can now a single
investigator single scientist can
actually ask really genome-wide
questions they can say of all 20,000
genes in the genome that's how many
genes are in the human genome
you know what are the effects of each of
these genes on the growth of a cancer
cell or on resistance to a cancer
therapy and so that's some of the
that we've been doing in my way and
asked all the genes at the same time all
the genes are the same time a single
scientist and that's that's really an
unprecedented scale where we can develop
libraries of crispers each with a
different guide RNA this component that
Sam mentioned that programs the castes
nine or Crisp or other CRISPR enzyme to
go to different places in the genome a
library of guide RNAs that target all of
the 20,000 genes in the genome and then
we can have this pool of cells and this
is again human cells this is the model
organism we care about in in biomedical
disease science and have this pool of
cells and then say which of these cells
now are resistant to a drug that they
shouldn't be in okay maybe this this
gene if we see a patient with a mutation
in this gene we now know we shouldn't
give them this drug we can predict in
advance of when they come into the
clinic that this might trigger
resistance these are the kind of we're
not quite there yet but this is this is
where this is heading
say let's say I have cancer and we're at
the stage where CRISPR is ready to help
me so how would how do you administer or
how will we administer CRISPR changed
medic medicines
yeah is it IV is it so I think it's
impossible to predict the future in this
field is changing rapidly but I think we
have a clue by the the clinical trials
that are just being registered right now
and a lot of them involve
taking advantage of the immune system
that's been a huge transformation in
cancer therapy or the last decade is the
introduction of immunotherapy first in
clinical trials and now in many
fda-approved medicines that encourage
the immune system to fight cancer and so
instead of administering drugs or
antibodies on a continual basis there's
the idea of taking out a small portion
of cells using gene editing to modify
those immune cells and then having
something that would not require
continuous administration maybe it would
be administered just once these are the
trials that are starting now with
campaigns on humans on humans maybe I
could talk about one example it's
actually
as far as I understand the first
clinical trial using gene editing in the
pre CRISPR day so it's a different
platform but same basic concept for
hiv-positive patients and the way this
clinical trial was administered is you
patients have immune cells removed from
their blood they're then edited at a
particular gene that's been known for
decades to confer resistance to HIV
viral infection so the ideas you
actually take a patient's own cells you
transform them into cells that can no
longer be infected by the virus but
they're otherwise still the patient's
own cells so it's not coming from a
donor where you have to worry about
immuno compatibility you edit the
patient's own cells and then you deliver
them back into the patient's bloodstream
where hopefully those cells will take
hold and now generate a new reservoir of
the patient's edited cells that have HIV
resistance and we'll pass on that
resistance to all cells that end up
coming from cell divisions and and and
if you can hit the stem cells even
better because now they're gonna have an
immortalized permanent line of cells in
their body that have been edited and can
never be infected by HIV what's amazing
about this is there is actually people
that carry this mutation naturally
there's a few very very lucky
individuals that are basically immune to
HIV and it's through studying the basic
disease mechanisms of that of those
kinds of individuals that we now know
what gene could be targeted in in the
rest of us to have HIV immune cells this
technology has been offered in an
open-source way so it is available for
scientists am I wrong about this all
around the world any lab unscrupulous
people or not it's even offered on the
web you can buy a CRISPR kit today
online so it is is is the horse out of
the barn or can we can we get something
at least a discussion a serious way to
make
or the things about what you're talking
about doesn't have to make sure some guy
isn't making a monster in the basement
you know all kinds of possibilities and
it seems that we're there and we haven't
talked about we should have talked about
it already we should have been
regulating it already why is it open
source for example like I only say
something about the open source because
I think the wrestler question is is very
important too but I think in terms of
science there's some examples where
things were a little bit less open
source today it's much easier to share
because of things like the internet but
you know previous technologies one
famous one is is PCR polymerase chain
reaction which is a very famous
technology in molecular biology
won a Nobel Prize allows us to very
easily amplify specific pieces of DNA it
was created in the mid 80s very powerful
technology that was initially patented
by the the company that that discovered
it and kept in a quite proprietary way
now it's widely disseminated I thinks
and it's different about the CRISPR
community and Sam's been a key part of
this too is that all the labs lab that I
came from Fung John's lab was really
pushed to the forefront the idea of very
quickly putting these these tools in a
non-profit repository called a gene that
would distribute them to any scientist
for a very nominal cost and to think I
mean there's there's some other things
you can focus on too but one thing
that's really important to bring up is
this is unusual in science how quickly
this has been shared and it's had a
unbelievably positive impact on allowing
biomedical scientists to just do a lot
more and a lot faster than thinking of
the downside so that's I'm gonna talk
about the upside okay maybe I don't you
can have something else but that's been
my experience and it's been it's really
been different than a lot of other
science and it's it's hard to overstate
that actually ya know none of the
scientists want to talk about the
downside I mean I didn't say a little
bit about Yu Suzuki
and in embryos and sperm and eggs and
things like that but I don't know the
answer to these questions about how it
stops somebody from ordering it over the
internet and using it in an animal and
then see it in a nefarious way but
certainly when it comes to humans so
even in the u.s. does not have
comparatively and an international sense
doesn't have a lot of federal regulation
that deals with in vitro fertilization
or these reproductive technologies other
countries some other countries like the
UK and Canada and Australia and various
other countries have sort of legislation
that regulates in overseas manipulation
of sperm eggs and embryo in embryos and
makes rules about what can and can't be
done a lot of those countries have laws
that say that you cannot make heritable
changes to human embryos for instance or
to their eggs or sperm so can't make a
change to the genes that will be passed
on now they might be reconsidering just
exactly how stringently they want to
stick to their even if it's positive
even so at this point yeah so that's but
just to say that you know in 1990 the UK
developed a regulatory regulatory scheme
in an oversight system for looking at
all of this and right now in the u.s.
there is a little bit of data collected
from IVF clinics so that we have some
idea of what's going on in terms of like
how many cycles of IVF are there and and
how do they use donor eggs any potential
use of these gene editing technologies
to make a baby would have to go through
the FDA what about saying you can't make
a change I mean in the embryo I think
that's something that needs to be
discussed and it is being discussed and
I mean Josephine earlier mentioned you
know Jennifer Doudna and a very large
group of scientists but also non
scientists importantly have been have
met you know 2015 there was an
international meeting I think there's
another one planned for the end of this
year and I think that's a critical piece
to really having a broad discussion
about what you know on a ethical and
social level should and shouldn't be
offered there's scientific
technicalities about you know off target
effects and unintended consequences but
I think there's also a bigger question
which is what kind of society you
we want to live in and what types of
interventions should be supported when
frankly there's a lot of other you know
social problems in our society that
would be addressed with a lot less money
than might be put into you know
generating genetically edited babies for
a very select few individuals so I think
it's you know whether or not arising it
your community is out having conferences
to discuss the ethics and what
regulation makes sense I mean the
National Academy of Sciences of the u.s.
did a whole report on the prospect of
using gene editing in humans including
to make changes that could be passed on
from one generation to the next and and
they're put they report they argued for
allowing potentially some heritable
changes but if they met certain really
strict criteria so for sort of stepping
a wee bit back from the idea that we
can't make a heritable change and saying
well maybe we can if we can show that
it's safe and effective and if it's a
disease that's really serious versus
like you know changing giving people
purple eyes or something so like there
was a being or there is a discussion
it's not just among scientists think
about heritable disease that you could
eliminate me from the face of the earth
I mean that's possible that's that's
part of this and why would anybody let's
say those rare cases where you have
parents that have no other option to
have their own child that will be free
of a disease no intervention as many
cycles of IVF and genetic screening of
embryos none of that will allow them to
have a child that doesn't inherit their
disease you could make a strong argument
for if there's a technology that can
address that problem and we can
administer it in a socially responsible
way should we have some red line that
says no if you change the DNA of an
embryo that's wrong but if you do it in
a patient that lives with the disease
that's okay I mean some people might say
why why are we making this distinction
we would be okay intervening surgically
on a newborn baby what's the issue with
doing it earlier in development if it's
a genetic intervention
and actually that's why the UK recently
changed their law around this issue to
allow for something called mitochondrial
replacement technology which isn't
CRISPR but it does introduce a heritable
change into the embryo and so they have
they had a whole public debate they
debated it in Parliament and they made a
change to the law to allow for this so I
do think that there are ways in which
regulatory structures can be adaptive to
these really compelling cases without
necessarily just opening the gates I'd
like to go back to the comment the two
of you made about getting rid of these
diseases this idea that if you had the
ability to get rid of the scourge and
that sounds like it's global and I guess
I just even if these technologies become
pretty feasible and I think Sam was
bringing this up who is gonna get to use
them you know are we really going to be
able to eliminate a disease like that
that requires us to mess around with an
embryo even if we're great at it when we
can't even give people enough to eat
right so who's gonna get it and who's
not gonna get it and that becomes a real
important social issue as to where are
you gonna go with this I salute you all
I hope that we didn't talk over your
head or under I hope we hit it just
right that was our goal so I want to
thank you all for the work you do
[Applause]
[Music]